There was a period in history between 1898
and 1922 dubbed the Heroic Age of Antarctic
Exploration.
It marked a time when daring adventurers set
their sights on one of the few lands that
still escaped humanity’s reach - the Antarctic.
And this land was harsh, cold, and unforgiving,
and all the people who dared face this unknown
knew there was a good chance they might not
come back.
Generally, 17 expeditions are considered part
of this era which made legends of men such
as Ernest Shackleton, Douglas Mawson, and
Robert Falcon Scott.
And, of course, there was Roald Amundsen,
the man we will be talking about today.
As the leader of the very first expedition
to reach the South Pole, Amundsen secured
his spot as one of the greatest explorers
in history.
But that was just one of his polar adventures,
as Amundsen was the type of man destined to
explore the frozen wilds forever.
Early Years
Roald Engelbregt Gravning Amundsen was born
on July 16, 1872, in the Norwegian parish
of Borge, near the capital of Oslo which,
back then, was called Christiania.
He was the youngest of four sons of Jens Engeberth
Amundsen and Hanna Gustava Sahlqvist, part
of a well-off maritime family who ran a shipping
business which, at its height, operated 22
vessels.
Soon after Roald’s birth, the family relocated
to Oslo where the four boys grew up.
Both parents wanted Roald to get a good education.
His mother, in particular, wanted him to avoid
life on the sea altogether and become a doctor.
But young Roald grew up with stories of famous
adventurers and explorers and wanted to emulate
them.
In school, he heard the tale of Franklin’s
lost expedition - how British explorer John
Franklin set off to find a way to traverse
the Northwest Passage and was never heard
from again.
The Northwest Passage is a sea route that
connects the Atlantic and Pacific Oceans by
passing through the Arctic Archipelago.
For centuries, charting this passage was a
holy grail for European sailors as it represented
a new, faster route to Asia, but many failed
in their attempts to safely navigate it.
Franklin set off with two ships, the HMS Erebus
and HMS Terror, and vanished.
Search attempts were all in vain and it wasn’t
until only a few years ago that both wrecks
were finally located.
Amundsen dreamt of succeeding where Franklin
failed.
Then, in 1889, the 17-year-old Roald was in
the crowd to witness the glorious return of
another great Norwegian explorer, Fridtjof
Nansen, after he became the first to traverse
the interior of Greenland.
Amundsen now knew that one day he wanted to
be a polar explorer just like his heroes.
Speaking of which, you can probably expect
to see Fridtjof Nansen featured in his own
Biographics video sometime in the future.
But getting back to Amundsen, he was torn
between two decisions.
On one hand, his life’s ambition was to
become an explorer.
On the other, he promised his mother that
he would study medicine.
In the end, he felt it was his duty to obey
his mother’s wishes so, in 1890, he enrolled
in the Royal Norwegian Frederick University
of Christiania to become a doctor.
However, when his mother died in 1893, Roald
ended his studies and set off on his true
passion.
It was probably for the best, though.
Not only did Amundsen end up becoming one
of the world’s greatest explorers, but it
was unlikely he would have ever graduated
from med school as he always had terrible
grades and showed little aptitude for book-learning.
The First Adventure
That same year, Amundsen set off on his first
adventure - a ski tour over the Hardanger
mountain plateau with two other men, Laurentius
Urdahl and Wilhelm Holst.
The inexperience of the skiers became evident
and the trio had to abandon their journey.
It wasn’t until five years later that Amundsen
attempted the ski tour again, this time successfully,
accompanied by his older brother, Leon.
Of course, in order to become a proper explorer,
life on land would not suffice.
Roald also had to master sailing.
Therefore, in 1894, he obtained his first
berth as an ordinary seaman aboard a seal-hunting
ship called the Magdalena.
This vessel was later renamed the Danmark
and was used by Danish explorer Ludvig Mylius-Erichsen
in 1906 in his ill-fated expedition to charter
the unknown northeast coastline of Greenland,
a mission which cost him his life and the
lives of his two senior officers.
As a sailor, Amundsen performed his work admirably
and quickly rose through the ranks.
Two years later, he got his first opportunity
at a true polar adventure when he was taken
on as a mate aboard the RV Belgica for the
Belgian Antarctic Expedition.
Captained by Belgian navy officer Adrien de
Gerlache, this voyage was a scientific mission
to the Antarctic.
Incidentally, it is also considered to be
the first expedition of the aforementioned
Heroic Age of Antarctic Exploration.
Roald Amundsen was not the only future explorer
aboard the vessel.
The ship’s physician was an American named
Frederick Cook.
He and Amundsen struck a lifelong friendship
and Cook would later achieve his own fame
(or, should we say, notoriety) when he claimed
to be the first person to reach the North
Pole.
His claim was challenged by his main rival,
Robert Peary, and the question of who actually
reached the geographic North Pole first is
still unsettled and highly controversial.
But more on that later…
As far as the Belgian expedition was concerned,
things were far from smooth sailing.
The crew of the Belgica became the first people
to spend the winter in the Antarctic.
This wasn’t by choice, mind you, but rather
because the ship became trapped in pack ice
in the Bellingshausen Sea.
The Belgica and its crew were stuck in these
icy conditions for 13 months, including two
months of perpetual darkness.
Some of the men, including de Gerlache, fell
gravely ill with scurvy while others began
losing their sanity.
It wasn’t until the start of 1899 that they
finally drifted near a stretch of open water.
It was still hundreds of yards out of reach,
so the men had to saw and dynamite through
their icy prison for a month in order to create
a channel for the ship to be able to move.
The expedition finally reached the Belgian
capital of Antwerp on November 5, 1899, where
the men received a hero’s welcome.
The Northwest Passage
Despite the many hardships, the Belgian Antarctic
Expedition was actually considered a success
as the crew collected a lot of scientific
data and discovered many new islands.
Moreover, it left Amundsen confident enough
that he was ready to lead his own expedition
and he even obtained the endorsement of his
hero, Fridtjof Nansen, who often gave the
young explorer advice and even, on occasion,
helped him secure financing.
As far as his objective was concerned, Amundsen
was not one for half measures.
Even though it was his first time as captain,
he wanted to fulfill his greatest ambition
- navigating through the Northwest Passage.
It was something that had been attempted many
times, but never succeeded all the way.
Moreover, it was something very dangerous,
which had claimed the lives of explorers far
more experienced than Amundsen.
That being said, the Norwegian adventurer
didn’t simply plunge into this mission headfirst
and hope for the best.
He did his homework.
In 1900, he visited German scientist and polar
explorer Georg von Neumayer who taught him
what he knew about the planet’s magnetic
field and how it affected instruments at the
poles.
While the geographic North Pole is the northernmost
point on Earth, from which all directions
point south, the magnetic North Pole moves
around all the time thanks to changes in the
planet’s core.
In fact, according to modern estimates, ever
since its formal discovery by British explorer
James Clark Ross in 1831, the magnetic North
Pole has traveled around 1,400 miles.
Amundsen didn’t need that kind of uncertainty
when heading in the right direction could
make the difference between life and death.
Next up, Amundsen needed a ship.
He wanted something small and sturdy, but
it also had to be cheap because he did not
have a lot of funds at his discretion.
In the end, he opted for a 45-ton sloop called
Gjøa.
It was much smaller than any ship that had
been used in the Northwest Passage before,
but Amundsen felt that its flexibility and
increased maneuverability suited his purposes.
Moreover, he also intended to use a very small
crew of only six people.
By comparison, Franklin’s lost expedition
had two ships and 129 crewmen, but Amundsen
concluded this was one of the missions’
fatal flaws as it severely stretched their
limited resources.
Moreover, it was his belief that every party
should only ever have the smallest number
of people possible needed to achieve its goals.
This way, everybody always had a clear assignment
and they felt that their efforts were vital
to the success of the mission.
In 1901, Amundsen had a ship, but still felt
unprepared to tackle the challenge he set
in front of him.
He spent the next two years making a trip
to the waters of Greenland to get acquainted
with his new vessel, plus to test out equipment,
provisions, and the crewmen he intended to
take on his expedition.
This sapped Amundsen’s funds and, against
his wishes, he had to reach out to creditors.
This was a problem that will haunt him for
most of his life.
According to one version of the story, Amundsen
and his crew had to sneak out of Oslo when
they started their mission as one of his creditors
intended to place the Gjøa under lien until
they were repaid.
Another version says that Fridtjof Nansen
had promised to take care of the debt while
Amundsen was at sea.
Whatever the truth might be, the Gjøa set
sail on June 16, 1903, headed for the Northwest
Passage.
The journey did not start off very auspiciously.
In the early parts of the expedition, there
was a fire in the ship’s engine room and
the vessel almost shipwrecked on an underwater
rock.
After these initial problems were dealt with,
however, things went a lot smoother as the
Gjøa crossed Baffin Bay and then managed
to navigate the multiple tight straits of
the Arctic Archipelago.
Some speculate that Amundsen could have made
the crossing in just one season, but the navigating
of the Northwest Passage was just one of the
expedition’s goals.
Other missions included collecting a ton of
scientific data and locating the new position
of the magnetic North Pole.
For this, the crew needed more time, so they
anchored in the natural harbor of King William
Island and let the ship get iced in.
Fortunately for them, the island had one human
settlement called Uqsuqtuuq which meant “lots
of fat” in the Inuktitut language, thus
named due to the abundance of seals in the
area.
The local Inuit people were happy to host
the Norwegian crew and showed them many useful
tips and techniques to survive the freezing
cold, tips which Amundsen took to heart and
would later employ during his conquest of
the South Pole.
The explorers spent almost two years there
before concluding their objectives and also
finding weather conditions suitable enough
to allow them to leave.
Internationally, the settlement is now better
known as Gjoa Haven for the role it played
in making polar history.
There were still more obstacles to overcome.
Near the Yukon, the ship got iced in again.
Worst of all, while Amundsen took a sled ride
to Eagle, Alaska, to send some telegrams,
one of his men, Gustav Wiik, fell ill and
died on March 31, 1906.
Amundsen later described him as the happiest
one in the group, always “full of humor
and stories”, who proved invaluable to maintaining
morale on the voyage.
On the stranger side of things, Amundsen also
found out on this occasion that the nation
and king that he served when he left on the
trip weren’t the same as the ones waiting
for him when he returned.
We’ve referred to Roald Amundsen as being
from Norway, although, technically, up until
this point, he was actually a citizen of the
United Kingdoms of Sweden and Norway.
Ever since 1814, the two countries had been
in a personal union where they kept separate
constitutions and administrations, but were
ruled by the same king.
In Amundsen’s time, that was King Oscar
II of Sweden.
However, the nations underwent a peaceful
dissolution in 1905 so, when Amundsen returned
home, he returned to a fully independent Norway
ruled by King Haakon VII.
Obstacles, tragedies, and political movements
aside, the Gjøa reached Nome, Alaska on August
31, 1906, officially completing its navigation
of the Northwest Passage.
Headed for
the North Pole
Daring feats like crossing the Northwest Passage
might make you famous and celebrated, but
they won’t make you rich.
For the next couple of years, Amundsen engaged
in writing and giving lectures to improve
his financial situation, but he disliked these
activities intensely.
What he wanted was to leave on another adventure,
not to sit behind a desk, but he had debts
to pay.
Even given his newfound fame, Amundsen was
having trouble finding creditors willing to
finance him.
What he needed was a new plan that will stir
up public interest.
In 1908, he approached the Norwegian Geographic
Society with a proposition - he wanted to
take the Fram (the ship that Fridtjof Nansen
used in his voyages) and recreate the latter’s
expedition to the Arctic Ocean, this time
with better preparation and more modern equipment.
This plan was received with enthusiasm by
the society, by the public, and by the king
who became one of the first donors to Amundsen’s
fundraising campaign.
This was at a time when there were multiple
expeditions undertaken to reach the North
and South Poles.
American explorer Robert Peary set a new Farthest
North record in 1906 while British adventurer
Ernest Shackleton was just 97 nautical miles
from reaching the South Pole in 1909.
Although it wasn’t explicitly stated during
the fundraising, it was widely believed that
Roald Amundsen would also make an attempt
for the North Pole, perhaps becoming the first
man to succeed in reaching one of the most
remote points on the planet.
The plan went down the drain in late 1909
when a new story reached the headlines - Frederick
Cook, Amundsen’s former shipmate aboard
the Belgica, had reached the North Pole.
His claim was attacked by Robert Peary who
also claimed to have reached the North Pole,
although he did it slightly later.
This launched a whole mess of arguments and
controversies that hasn’t been completely
sorted even today.
Cook’s claim was dismissed by many not necessarily
as false, but as being unproven, while Peary’s
was accepted, but with a lot of hesitation,
and many experts have retroactively dismissed
his claim, as well.
None of this mattered in the moment, though.
Either one, or both, or neither of them reached
the North Pole, but the headlines said they
did so, all of a sudden, it wasn’t seen
as the “holy grail” of polar exploration
anymore.
It had been done which meant that interest
in Amundsen’s planned expedition started
to dwindle and the fundraising dried up.
This was around the same time that Shackleton
tried and failed to reach the South Pole so
Amundsen thought that maybe he could still
salvage his expedition by changing his destination
from the North to the South Pole.
He had strong competition.
Another British explorer, Robert Falcon Scott,
or Scott of the Antarctic, as he later came
to be known, had already made preparations
and announced his intentions to sail for the
South Pole should Shackleton not succeed.
His party, the Terra Nova Expedition, left
Cardiff in June, 1910.
On his end, Amundsen had decided to make the
switch, but did not tell anyone apart from
a few close confidants.
He was heavily in debt and had to mortgage
his own house to fund the expedition after
newspapers cancelled their sponsorships.
He knew that only a sensational feat will
help him raise funds and that wasn’t to
be found at the North Pole anymore.
If he went public with his new intentions,
he risked having his expedition delayed or
cancelled altogether, thus giving Scott the
best chance at succeeding.
Amundsen knew he would be criticized for his
underhanded tactic and, indeed, he was.
Mainly, he was accused of entering a race
against Scott which was not only unscientific,
but also endangered the men of both expeditions.
A Change of Plans
The Fram left Norway on August 9, eight weeks
after the Terra Nova Expedition.
At this point, most of the 19 crewmen aboard
the ship still thought they were headed for
the North Pole.
It wasn’t until they stopped at Madeira
for new provisions that Amundsen informed
them of his new plan and also wrote a telegram
to tell Scott, as well.
The South Pole Expedition reached Antarctica
in January, 1911, and set up a base camp on
a natural ice harbor called the Bay of Whales
on the Ross Ice Shelf.
They named this camp Framheim Station.
At one point, they even met a small party
from the Terra Nova Expedition who was exploring
the area.
On the surface, relations between the two
groups were cordial, although Amundsen later
confessed that he was relieved when he discovered
that the British crew had no wireless radio
as he feared they might have been able to
send word of their success first even if he
reached the South Pole before them.
Here was where Amundsen’s previous experiences
in polar situations, as well as the techniques
he learned from the Inuit people, came into
play.
He and his men wore furred skins like the
Inuits instead of the traditional heavy wool
clothing.
They subsided on a meat-rich diet as Amundsen
observed during his stint aboard the Belgica
that it helped ward off scurvy.
Most importantly, the Norwegian relied completely
on dog sleds and skis for transportation.
He brought almost 100 Greenland dogs with
him on his trip as they could also be used
for meat along the way.
Scott, on the other hand, had a certain aversion
to using dogs as he considered them unreliable.
He employed a mixed transportation method
consisting of dogs, Siberian ponies, and motorized
sledges.
The sledges were supposed to be the ace up
his sleeve, except they were the exact opposite.
First of all, one of them they lost while
unloading the ship.
Furthermore, they increased the cargo load
since the party had to carry fuel for them.
But most importantly, they weren’t capable
of handling the extreme weather and the others
broke down early into the trip.
By comparison, Amundsen’s journey went a
lot smoother, although he, too, flirted with
disaster once.
After months of setting up the Framheim Station,
a party of eight set off for the South Pole
in September, 1911.
This was done only to get a headstart on the
British.
Amundsen soon realized that they set off too
early and should have waited for the polar
spring for better weather conditions.
They returned to Framheim, but lost a lot
of good dogs on the way and several of the
men were sidelined with severe frostbite.
It also led to an argument between Amundsen
and one of his officers, Hjalmar Johansen,
who accused him of acting foolishly to beat
Scott.
Unsurprisingly, Johansen was left out of the
next South Pole party that departed a month
later.
This revised party only included five men,
as well as 52 dogs and four sledges.
The men were Roald Amundsen, Helmer Hanssen
who had also been part of his Northwest Passage
crew, Olav Bjaaland, Oscar Wisting, and Sverre
Hassel.
These were the first men to reach the South
Pole, thanks partly to finding a good, clear
route on top of a previously-undiscovered
glacier which Amundsen named Axel Heiberg
Glacier.
On December 14, 1911, the party arrived at
their destination.
They raised a little tent they named Polheim,
planted the Norwegian flag, and left behind
a letter for Scott or whomever else may find
it should they fail to return.
They were very diligent in their calculations,
wanting to make sure they had the right spot
and avoid a situation like that between Peary
and Cook up in the North Pole.
Scott’s party arrived a month later on January
18, 1912.
Amundsen’s team made it back to Framheim
in late January and quickly began packing
everything up on the ship to leave for Australia
and send word of their success.
Of course, Amundsen didn’t know it at the
time, but there was no reason to hurry as
Scott’s entire party tragically died on
the way back.
North Pole by Air
When he was back home, Amundsen once again
began planning a drift expedition on the Arctic
Ocean like Fridtjof Nansen had done before
him.
He bought and fitted a new ship named Maud,
but his plans were put on hold by World War
I.
He eventually set off in 1918, but this turned
out to be his worst venture ever.
Problems kept cropping up that caused delay
after delay.
Six years had passed and the expedition had
not fulfilled its mission.
Amundsen was, once again, heavily in debt
and all his creditors had lost their patience
with him and demanded repayment, including
his own brother.
The explorer had no other choice - in September,
1924, he declared bankruptcy and lost his
ship.
For a while, it seemed like Amundsen’s adventuring
days had come to an end, as he began giving
lectures in the United States to make money.
However, the opportunity for one last hurrah
presented itself in the form of Lincoln Ellsworth,
a rich American with an interest in polar
exploration.
Ellsworth was willing to fund more expeditions
to the North Pole, as long as he was part
of the group.
In the previous years, Amundsen had tried
and failed to fly over the Pole but now, with
Ellsworth’s backing, he was ready to try
again.
First, in 1925, Amundsen, Ellsworth, and four
other men took two Dornier Do J flying boats
and almost reached 88° north which, at the
time, was the northernmost latitude ever achieved
by plane.
They had to stop short because one of the
aircrafts was damaged and had to land.
However, just a year later, Amundsen and a
crew of 16 went aboard an Italian airship
called the Norge and successfully flew over
the geographic North Pole.
Assuming that both Peary and Cook’s controversial
claims of reaching the North Pole were incorrect,
as well as that of an American pilot named
Richard Byrd who also made a disputed claim
of flying over the Pole, this would be the
first verified successful attempt of reaching
the geographic North Pole.
Even if it wasn’t, the flight still made
Amundsen (and one of his trusted companions,
Oscar Wisting), the first men to travel to
both the North and South Poles.
In the end, Roald Amundsen considered that
that was about as good as it got and he finally
retired, although not for long.
Just two years later, the 55-year-old Amundsen
and a team of five boarded a Latham 47 flying
boat to assist in the search & rescue of a
crashed airship.
Amundsen’s aircraft disappeared on June
18, 1928.
It is presumed that it crashed in the Barents
Sea, although the bodies of Roald Amundsen
and his crew were never found.